does the brain count as meat let me
fight the cow brain like that's me right
yeah I think so
can't you get isn't cup paisa cabeza is
is head in Spanish I think right so yeah
when you get that at a taco truck you're
getting so this is what Barack is
getting right here so clearly that was
like a huge team world combat that that
right there was like unexpected though I
was kind of like oh it's gonna be brutal
it's gonna be gory or whatever he's
gonna like stab them in the face and
they'll be the end of it and then rips
out her brain and starts eating him like
you know you didn't have to do that but
you also saw a dude like knock a brain
out of a skull by slicing off the face
first and then hitting him in the back
of it but here you do that true yeah
yeah that's where I draw the line
[Music]
you guys play the game too so brains
brains popping out as normal never been
part of the experience but I mean what
are we looking at here because we're
combat X and justice to those games are
like nether realms bread and butter you
can see them kind of iterating on a
bunch of ideas even in different series
and it kind of looks like they took the
best of both worlds and combined it into
this you you know you're a born familiar
with fighting games mournful milliard
more fiddly I can't hear myself you're
more familiar with fighting games that
fighting game mechanics yeah you said
that you played a lot of injustice - I
did play a lot of injustice - and I
think it it's a little bit different for
more combat 11 you know there's there's
I think the game is a lot slower now
because they remove the run they remove
or they remove dashing but they made it
a lot less effective right so that your
I think the characters are a little bit
more intertwined with footsies as
opposed to like rushing down people so
like you know being careful with your
with your moves but a lot I feel like a
lot of the moves also push your
character forward so there's still like
you still get that aggressors a lot of
momentum built into some of the move
sets yeah I think like the injustice
stuff I was talking about was like the
the gear that you wear oh that was a
huge part of
Yeah right and that's a huge part of
this now right so in a way yes but it's
not like injustice to we actually talked
to Ed Boon and he mentioned that instead
of getting one piece of gear and having
the stats only applied to that gear it's
like you can customize you can figure
out what your character wants to look
like first and then say okay now I want
that hat to have this ability or this
stat on okay so you have control over
both aspects yeah yeah so you're not
tying yourself to like one piece of gear
because it had does anything yes okay
but can we can we talk about some of
these more fatalities too because I just
keep coming back to them and I'm still
I'm just constantly amazed at just what
they can come up with I think that's
like still one of the most impressive
things to me no I I did ask that
question though because I think that's
like one of the more fascinating things
about Mortal Kombat and I specifically
asked him like yo how do y'all keep like
one upping yourselves on all this nasty
gory stuff yo and it's like he laid it
out for me and he was like all right we
have a team meeting we get into a room
and we have everyone bring their ideas
we bring in our paper we write down our
ideas on paper then we present them to
the to the team like what is this play
this is like a like a like a class
presentation on the most like that thing
you can come up with and he's like
sometimes we tell each other a you know
that kind of crosses the line but most
of the time we have an idea and then we
kind of go from there and kind of build
off of that say yeah well rip his head
off and then we'll shoot into a chopper
and the chopper will chop his brain off
then baraka will eat it like you know ed
booted I followed up by asking like do
you ever step back and think to yourself
like man what am I doing with my life
and he's kind of like oh we keep each
other in check make sure we just like
any the funniest part is it ed boon has
such a like a gentle demeanor like such
a mystery nice soft-spoken dude
and kind of like you came up with more
combat like this is your project all
right I feel that the other fatality is
to have the one fatal blow so yeah
there's also fatal blows which are in
essence like a finisher it's not a
fatality at the end of the round it's
more like a super move basically so once
you're at 30% you get the ability to
just do a whole bunch of damage with a
single move and they're just as
cinematic as fatalities but you know
they get up to very unusually yeah this
is sort of like a comeback mechanic yeah
which is why they give it to you once
you're at like 30 percent or less health
right and it does quite a bit of damage
so it is pretty effective as a comeback
mechanic you can only use it once per
match yeah so you might have to think
about when you use it but I think that
it's it's not tied to any meters except
for your home that's the only yes so
it's all he tied to your health so
you'll get it you'll get it no matter
what you don't don't worry about
expending leader or saving meter for
like oh maybe I'll need to use the fatal
blow yeah later on but so it's just
there for you to use if you need it are
you guys feeling about just the game in
general cuz I'll be honest like I'm I
was really excited to see more about
Mortal Kombat but now that I'm looking
at it I do worry that like maybe it's
too soon for another one really ya know
I mean for me personally though that's
what I'm asking what you guys think but
like I feel like boy Kombat 10 was
really good at what it did and it's
still probably a pretty viable game I'm
not seeing like hugely like you know new
things here that are like oh wow I can't
wait to play Mortal Kombat because of
this I definitely see that I think that
talking to a lot of people at the event
itself I think that they're seeing a lot
on more on the granular level in terms
of like when he mentioned
how movement has changed how it's a
little bit slower how dashes are kind of
tempered back and how the meters work
with offense and defense being separated
so you have a lot more combat options
more comments a big mainstream series
though it's not right a fighting game
key right yeah and then so what when you
do have that concern be like I'm not
really seeing him like I kind of I kind
of agree with you in that sense so I
mean I don't know more brutal Bulls I
guess it's kind of the attracting point
but I mean the more stuff I pay
attention to was like those more
granular details because that's because
that's where my headspace is at but yeah
if you were probably watching the
presentation and like thinking about
like okay why would I want to jump into
this you know and just as he was only
two years ago MKX still feels like a new
game even though that came out like a
little while ago like four years ago
I do feel you on that maybe it's too
soon I don't think so
I think they've they've got a good thing
going with like the success of injustice
- and I feel like they've learned a lot
going from Mortal Kombat to injustice in
as far as like cinematic like the way
they portray their characters because
it's not only you know the fighting
there's like injustice to head of really
I would say it's a really impressive
story as well so I think they're also
gonna do that with this like one of the
main things I feel like they've learned
from injustice was to make sure that
this game is a whole package like a
complete package with the K like on the
start like there are so many fighting
games that I feel that have kinda been
released from bare bones with the idea
that okay later on we'll add DLC we'll
add like a story mode we'll add you know
more fighters like a season pass like
they lay out this plan before it's even
released where mobile combat feel like
if they're gonna have what kind of 11
they will have like a lot to do it's
like just from the start I think that's
the launch product seems like it's gonna
add a lot to go with it I almost forgot
about the story stuff but when I caught
up with with Ed and I asked him like
okay like catch me up on what you guys
are doing with the story stuff and he's
like and what I also asked about the
lessons learned from injustice - its
kind of like yeah we want to bring a
more cinematic approach to this because
we've had success with it in the past
and moral Kombat brings along like a I
guess not a deep lore but it has a
storied history you know it's a so they
could leverage that to create maybe
something unique
they have creative freedom with these
characters that people have some
attachment to and I think that will show
through in this a lease from that that
seems like their approach and you know
they had a cinematic story though for
Ted they did write like it's not like
they haven't done that for the writers
before so like but I also did see a lot
of people really hyped for where this is
taking lore what its gonna do with these
characters which I never I never looked
immortal combat that way
right so now they've got like what a new
villain time travel with Kron chronic
come on come on Iike Chronicle
yeah and then they also have the new
character Garris who's supposed to be
sent me basically but oh yeah okay yeah
we were just talking about him he's like
a combination of because he's may have
San and can like deuce and move like he
can also stop time so he's like Prince
of Persia mixed with he said danos that
would do this disease he looks like okay
with the big yeah yes he has a big-ass
gauntlet and I'm like is he Thanos no do
fists and whirling are his eyes doofus
but then he has like yeah like I said he
controls like sand and Prince of Persia
and time stuff so that I think that
Garris is a new character might might
bring more than you would expect more
than just being a new character because
is also being weaved into the story and
well I don't know what's gonna come out
of that but yeah with bringing chronica
and having Garrity's like that an ally
to whoever that character is it seems
like they have a lot more to work with
then like Scorpion and sub-zero no
rivals I'm gonna fight each other at
this temple or something so they're
trying I guess so more than the original
Mortal Kombat yeah yeah it's just about
up so yeah yeah I guess it's really too
early to tell anything about the story
speaking of scorpion sub-zero sure
[Music]
I mean yeah this cooler comment is just
such takes brutality it's just a
fascinating direction that like I mean
it started the government's sort of like
wanting to crackdown on video games and
stuff and then here we are today and
it's like everyone this is great yeah
look forward to there's a lot of
embracing of that gory style because
it's it doesn't take itself too
seriously it does look I don't think
it's up seriously at all yeah yeah I
mean on any morally yeah and is for the
better like I want it to be like
over-the-top and cartoony yeah otherwise
I'd be next step suey we streams my
favorite moment from the event oh there
was a lot of there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of stuff at the event I
think probably my favorite is like this
box that they had that people if you
could walk into it and then just like
smash stuff for a couple minutes
oh yeah it's right here covered in blood
but there's just like old equipment in
there they just give you a sledgehammer
you just bash stuff seems very cathartic
that they have a booth or someone can
just punch you in the face they had a
fatality room I didn't know I'm not sure
if this is it but I think it's the photo
op that
[Music]
it was a fatality photo okay the
fatality room is somewhere else where
you just die sick
my favorite was probably see if sonic
Fox played and that was kind of a I
guess I I kind of expected him to be
there because he's like the iconic
figure of the fighting game community
but I saw him there and I was like hey
just play well combat and like I was
following his tweets at the event too
because I didn't get to talk to him and
he was like kind of breaking down how he
felt about the game in comparison to MKX
I don't know that was just a really cool
thing to see like this this guy who's
kind of like blew up as an icon and then
like just you know seeing him there and
working with the game and like talking
about how he feels about the game I
thought that was the that's my favorite
part
there was someone um custom painting
shoes also oh yeah and you can get a
tattoo there you're right yeah
they have a little loss of going there
kind of went they went they went for it
yeah they broke the bank on this and
rightfully so just because I can see
Mona LMB being a pretty big deal when it
does come out yeah specially with that
$300 Edition wasn't that collector's
edition with the mask is through alright
total surprise you know it's funny her
life Joey was saying that the event is
like what if they have like the
collector's edition and just like a
severed head close enough maybe next
time yeah will sever heads next time so
let's get it
[Music]